ouah ouah la vache c'est quoi cette
cuisine j'en ai vu de bien j'en ai vu de
toutes les couleurs mais franchement ça
fait peur c'est quand même un sacré
c'est à dire
c'est à dire comment je peux tu
expliquer
[Musique]
le chat batterie
alors quand je le dois
[Applaudissements]
mais là on est pour toi c'est en
projection au festival de cannes vous
êtes rassurés tout va bien agi par appât
du tout si le produit ils sont ils sont
bienveillants mais oui c'est connu quand
même dix minutes d'applaudissements pour
le proche pour le précédent vous
souvenez est cependant quelques fois
vous pouvez penser ça peut se renouveler
oui mais vous imaginez bien de vendée
avait semé le vent on ne prend le port
ce qu'est ce qu'on a raté on ne pense
qu'à ça je ne cesse de me le dire
[Musique]
tilda swinton qui avait été mans
souriant 2010
j'aurais été présidée par quentin
tarantino
ils ont remis la palme d'or à michael
moore pour
heinz 1 et les vannes a fourni dans cet
état là un seul couvert en une matinée
là on au service d'un cap ou un truc
comme ça tu vois quand je vois ça j'ai
envie de dégueuler c'est pas possible
mais qu'il n'a pas faire bouffer dans un
lieu tel que celui ci
c'est pas c'est pas humain c'est
pitoyable c'est lamentable
épisode pas perdre de temps dit sur
canal+ on est fier de ce jeudi on
mangeait rien foutu
[Rires]
et ce projet j'ai très bien de se manger
je viens d'abord riche attend on a la
fierté des spectateurs tout mettre les 8
ou et ouais quand tu es un peu sensible
donc tu es tu es honnête était un peu à
fleur de peau bah ça peut se transformer
en quelque chose de l'ordre de la
sauvagerie alors qui a absolument rien
de sauvage chez c'était comme ça quoi
mais c'est vrai que je suis pas adepte
du de l'accolade du sourire de tout un
tas de choses qui sont très présentes
dès fois dans nos métiers que je ne sais
pas faire malheureusement pas grave
merci non graves pascal à présent tu
t'en fous même donc la façon de dire
c'est pas grave comme un moulin à
paroles
souvent très bien sous laon moi je les
contrôles d'hygiène je suis battu et
combien
et toi tu as une personne connue fait un
mec qui déboula et si tu fermes ta
restaurant je te le dire de suite
alors c'est quoi qu'est ce que tu veux
tu veux des coups de pioche tu veux que
j'arrivais pitch touches je te foute une
avoinée parce que c'est pas foutu de
tenir ta cuisine c'est pour ça que tu me
fais venir
c'est la belle main avec aux chaînes
parce que j'étais à l'oeil alors
j'espère que il va pas me la fatigue et
qui restera toujours au fond parce que
je promenais gpo fils et le père c'est
ici dans cette zone résidentielle que
l'alligator sèment la terreur un
attroupement s'est formé sur le trottoir
bonjour
sous la voiture il y à bien un alligator
les badauds n'en reviennent pas
moi je voulais pas m'approcher pourquoi
qui par tomber
mais on a monté le membre de toutes les
couleurs maintenant croyable mais brille
cyril lignac est avec nous vous avez
vous pendant la coupure pub vous avez un
petit truc
ainsi quelle remontée rapide à petit en
toute amitié mélanie doutey aussi et
puis vous à la maison au regard c'est
mignon le type un barbecue tu fais des
soirées là tu es la regarde pas ses
intentions une petite brochette on suit
un petit barbecue on n'est pas bien là
regarde au milieu du bon biais 1 c'est
pas sympathique
bien il dit y avoir bien voir on passe
un petit moment tranquille dans un
espace privilégié
on se croirait presque au bord de la mer
mais bernard va vite faire redescendre
la fièvre des riverains non violent du
plastique
il en plastique
voilà c'est un faux
hellin plastique regardez made in china
donc on va leur amener avec nous
la capture du jour les passants ont
mordu à l'hameçon de ce qui ressemble à
une mauvaise blague